[Music]
hey youtubers is Charlie so they
revealed a whole bunch of stuff about
arrow episode 1 so let's break this down
there's a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video we actually know quite a bit about
the first episode one there's going to
be a flashback to explain how they got
off the island but it sounds like when
the episode picks up present-day will be
three months down the road just like it
is on every show so they did the same
thing on the flash during season 2 where
they explain how Ronnie died in the
season 1 finale even though in the
opening moments they made it seem like
something else happened it was all
taking place in his head they've already
teased some production art for season 6
there's a new Black Canary mantle that
holds laurels old costume this doesn't
belong to Dinah Drake she has a costume
that'll hang where the normal costumes
saying the whole thing last season was
about whether or not she would take up
the mantle is she going to take a code
name is she going to use the Black
Canary name is she going to wear laurels
costume so this makes it seem like the
costume that Dinah Drake wears will be
different from laurels they'll find a
way to memorialize that while at the
same time having Katie Cassidy on is
black siren so they can tease maybe
she'll wear that costume at some point
although I don't think it's going to
happen soon the cast list is pretty much
confirmed they're only a couple
characters I don't they are going to
show up the only people I'm not
expecting to see are Nyssa Talia Merlyn
in Captain Boomerang now I think the
Italian asar still alive the only reason
I don't think that we're going to see
them is just because the actresses are
busy doing other things so they'll come
back and get star every once in a while
it'll be fun to see them battle it out
see whether or not one of them is going
to reform the League of Assassins
eventually but obviously Merlyn is
supposed to be dead even though I think
they fixed it so that he can come back
and get star in the future the whole
reason for making him seem dead is
because John Barrowman was ready to
leave the show he just wanted to do
other things and they wanted to give
some important character development for
Thea's character so she has to deal with
losing her father again they're just
going to be part of her arc in bringing
Merlyn right back would completely
negate that or showing him escaping so
even if he did survive I don't think
they're going to tell you I think they
he'll just show up in a future episode
and it'll either be a hallucination in
Thea's mind or it'll actually be him and
like surprise I'm back but I
don't think he's ever going to be a
series regular on the TV show again the
people that are definitely confirmed to
be coming back are Oliver William black
siren Dinah Drake Deathstroke in the
flashback to explain how he got off the
island then Diggle wild dog Thea in mr.
terrific in Felicity to og team arrow is
safe pretty much everybody on Team arrow
is safe he didn't think that they were
going to kill all those people off the
only thing is that people are wondering
about William's mother because if the
theme of season six is family it's all
about the family that is team arrow
about Oliver's literal family in Thea
and William his son there's no way that
they're going to have Oliver be a dad
every single episode but William will be
an important part of the season so I
think that she did survive but they'll
just be a bigger part of his life and
they have been in the past like you see
them pop up every once in a while
throughout the season you'll probably
see them come back but I don't think
that William is going to be a main cast
member or he's gonna have like a really
big story he'll just come back for a
couple really cool episodes and that'll
be it the only confirmed villain that we
have right now is a mysterious group
from Oliver's passed in vigilante
separatly two completely separate
concepts they talk about this group in
the synopsis for season six they release
it says Oliver has finally solidified
and strengthened his crime-fighting team
only to have it threatened when
unexpected enemies from his past return
to Star City forcing Oliver to rethink
his relationship with each member of his
family Marc Guggenheim did tweet out a
joke when the alien movie came out
saying that oh we should say now that
the arrow villain for season 6 is going
to be covenant because of alien
prometheus alien covenant then arrow
season five premieres arrow season six
covenant so no idea if he was actually
just joking or if he was literally
teasing the villain but it sounds like
it was more of a joke the only real
organization that we know is confirmed
to be coming back at some point is the
Bratva
the way they ended things sounded like
they are now officially over they're out
for Oliver's blood but they're not
enemies from Oliver's past they were
friends from the past so whoever the new
villain is going to be it'll be somebody
that we haven't seen on the show before
with the exception of vigil and
so the big vigilante thing is that it
was sort of a tease through season five
they would just pop up below a bunch of
stuff up and then fade into the night
goodbye but when people ask the
producers are we ever going to find out
who's underneath the mask they said oh
that's not going to happen till season
six so it just means the vigilante is
going to be bigger in season six than
they were in season five so I know
there's a lot of theories about who's
underneath there like maybe it's Roy
who's gone a little bit nuts they've
kind of already done that plot when we
have some more evidence I'll do a who is
vigilante video because I honestly don't
think that it's going to be somebody
that we've seen before but I do think
it'll be an important character Oliver
is still going to be mayor queen Diggle
we'll still have all the Argus LYLAS
stuff going on so any suicide squad
based story will come through diggle's
character you remember that they teased
the gorilla grodd lead Suicide Squad
that were trapped in the basement so
they'll come back but that's mostly a
flash thing that they tease so we'll see
whether or not arrow gets to make use of
that they might turn that into their
four and I cross over but I think that
will be something even bigger black
sirens character is mostly all about
Redemption whether or not she cares to
seek Redemption if she's going to try
and form a new family with Quentin even
though he's not her father will she ever
wear laurels old costume again I don't
think that she will I think she's going
to be bad for most of the season but bad
in the way the killer frost is bad so
think of her when you're thinking of
black siren so she's not going to be
evil all the time but she'll be more
evil than Catelyn the new Black Canary
Dinah Drake is all about embracing that
role even more she's a police officer so
obviously she'll have all the detective
work but then she really didn't wear the
Black Canary costume during season five
so we'll probably just get closer to
that and then obviously mr. terrific is
just going to have all kinds of crazy
gadgets more fun with the t spheres sake
burns I don't think we'll ever get to
the point where he's flying on top of
the t spheres just because they're too
small and even though arrow does do some
funny stuff every once in a while just
seeing him try to balance on those tiny
balls and fly around feels too
ridiculous for arrow Deathstroke story
will mostly take place off screen
because I think that the new Bennet's
mostly going to be busy doing his other
TV show so while he's doing is just
trying to track down his son Joe Wilson
Jo
he'll probably find it and I'm expecting
to see Deathstroke in the costume but
Manu Bennett without the costume on is a
different story it just depends on his
availability and as for Titans
Deathstroke stuff the Titans TV show
confirmed it's going to be filming in
Toronto not in Vancouver with the other
CW shows they've got their four
characters I've already done a video
about it I'll link that at the end of
this but it sounds like they'll work up
to Deathstroke so we're not going to see
him in that first episode they haven't
revealed what the plot of the four night
crossover is going to be but the
Supergirl episode will be much more
substantial and because arrow doesn't
have an anniversary that it's
celebrating they'll be able to use their
episode to drive the plot forward with
all the characters instead of being a
more nostalgic look back on the series
itself if you didn't know they moved the
show to Thursdays at 9:00 p.m. so
episode 1 will air Thursday October 12
at 9:00 p.m. but Canada is still airing
their episodes Wednesday nights
so what I'll probably do is I'll just
post my episode video after it airs on
Wednesday nights and you can watch it
whenever you see the episode but what
I'll do is I'll just pick a day at a
time to post my video and keep it the
same for the entire season I think there
was a problem this year finding videos
because the schedule was all weird
they moved legends of tomorrow to
Tuesday nights that's still on Tuesday
nights so when they drop all the Comic
Con trailers I'll remind everybody when
the shows are airing what the schedule
is going to be because there is some
stuff that's happening on Friday night
but that's mostly Marvel TV agents of
shield and Inhumans so arrowverse is
largely the same with the exception of
arrow believe all your bonus video
requests in the comments below there'll
be new flash this weekend while I was
making this video they started to tease
what the full and I crossover was going
to be about so that's probably what my
flash video will be about this weekend
but this new Game of Thrones there's new
Rick and Morty season 3 so we'll just
announce the next giveaway winner when I
post my next DC video while you wait for
that click here to learn all about
episode 1 of Titan and you can click
here for brand new game of throne thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you